2021 threw a lot at us but one thing we
know for sure is that it's set up 2022
for gaming success we saw the rise or
return of older titles indies rivaling
aaa and also some major flops that have
since raised our expectations today
we're talking about some major reasons
why 2022 is an exciting year for games
leave a like subscribe and let's get to
it
in 2020 and 2021 we not only got used to
game delays we grew to appreciate them
after seeing some major launch day flops
uh i'm looking at you cyberpunk 2077 and
server issues from games like new world
and battlefield 2042 we grew to
understand that more time in the oven
isn't necessarily a bad thing of course
we all just want to get our hands on the
latest games already while ignoring our
massive backlogs however patience is a
virtue 2020 and 2021's long list of
delays have 2022 jam-packed full of
launches from the highly anticipated
elden ring which was originally set to
release in november of 2021 to god of
war ragnarok and horizon forbidden west
which both initially had 2021 release
windows and that's just to name a few
other delays that helped beef up 2022
include ghostwire tokyo the latest from
legendary developer sinji mikami scorn
gotham knights and more we've also
rounded up every delay from 2021 that
you can check out on our channel right
now
but enough talk about delays let's talk
about the huge number of interesting and
exciting games on the way in 2022 both
marvel and dc are going to be showing up
in a big way marvel's midnight sons is
the latest tactical rpg from x-com
developers for axis featuring a number
of your favorite marvel heroes meanwhile
dc is bringing out the big guns suicide
squad kills the justice league and
gotham knights are looking to be fresh
takes on dc's heroes and villains
franchise with no shortage of flashy
graphics and while 2021 may have had
some disappointments throughout the year
at least we could rely on nintendo to
deliver some great presentations that
kept us enticed with each nintendo
direct and announcement we've been glued
to our screens for just a drop of news
on games such as the legend of zelda
breath of the wild 2 bayonetta 3 and
pokemon legends rks which are all set to
release this year and what we've seen so
far has been top notch of course we all
love familiar ips sequels and spin-offs
but 2022 is also bringing a whole lot of
new entirely new worlds and characters
are being introduced to us as we see
developers like square enix diving into
a brand new world with force spoken
where they literally take a young new
yorker and toss her in to a brand new
world
bethesda is embarking on new adventures
with starfield and red fall and
ghostware tokyo and others create
interesting takes on characters we know
and love so whether you want to explore
deep space or wheeled magic you can
we've got a preview on for a spoken on
our website and also a list of all the
other biggest games coming to 2022 in
the card above
but it'd be remiss to discuss
interesting fresh ideas in games and not
talk about indies indie games are not
only in abundance but are also rivaling
aaa titles games from 2021 such as kenna
bridge of spirits chicory a colorful
tale and before your eyes prove that to
be true more indie developers are also
getting access to partnerships and
resources to bring their unique
perspectives to life which is definitely
a win for us
sifu and stray are two games i've been
eyeing respectfully for quite some time
the kung fu hand-to-hand combat of sifu
looks amazing and i desperately want to
explore life as an alley cat in stray
both are already delivering their own
unique types of serotonin and i am here
for it there is also no shortage of
unique indie games on the way whether
you prefer a strategy game like tara nil
a sim like thirsty suitors
dime to cook or an action adventure game
like little devil inside
and this is just the tip of the iceberg
when it comes to indie titles and we're
really gonna see them blossom in 2022 is
there an indie game you've got your eye
on that more people should know about
let me know in the comments
streaming services like xbox game pass
and playstation now have also changed
the way i look at new releases as
someone who's gone mostly digital in
2021 having new games available day one
on a service i'm subscribed to makes it
a no-brainer to hop in and play it's an
added bonus to playing and discovering
hundreds of other games on the platform
in between major releases i'm also an
absolute sucker for free games when it
comes to games with gold epics free
games playstation plus games and more
i've managed to fill up my digital
library with a lot of unique games
throughout the last few years and this
is a trend i really want to see continue
you always have a chance to stumble upon
a game you wouldn't have tried before
but end up really liking i remember when
i first played 2018's god of war for the
first time on playstation now and i
loved the game so much that i was
kicking myself for being a year late to
the party in 2021 i also became slightly
addicted to minecraft and when it was
added to game pass i was able to get a
bunch of friends who have a subscription
to try it out for the first time now we
have an awesome realm where we've built
some really cool stuff
it's so much easier to convince your
friends to play something with you if
they have it readily available to stream
the fact that game streaming extends
beyond single player titles and allows
us to play multiplayer games really
solidifies its value for me and has me
looking forward to what could be added
in 2022
for better or for worse it's always cool
when your favorite game gets its own
movie or show please don't let me down
halo but i think it's even more cool in
reverse as long as it's done right
luckily for us gaming has become such a
powerhouse outlet of entertainment that
it only makes sense that franchises like
the lord of the rings marvel star trek
and the expanse have games in the works
however a few other ips are getting
games this year too that might surprise
you if you haven't already heard if you
enjoyed a quiet place and it's sequel
then you'll get to experience an untold
story of survival set in its universe
and hot off the heels of the movie dune
is once again entering the gaming space
with a new strategy game called dune
spice wars we saw so many collaborations
and crossovers in 2021 between games and
entertainment which resulted in just
about all of your favorite characters
joining fortnite and has blasted the
door wide open for even more
possibilities including concerts and
events that you just had to see to
believe we even had a playable matrix
experience that not only showed off on
roll 5 but was a good promo for matrix
resurrections which ultimately brings us
to our next point
the matrix awaken was designed to show
off the capabilities of unreal 5 which
has only convinced me that this year
will be showing off some amazing new
things and if you're anything like me
that means your expectations are going
to be a lot higher this time around too
developers are becoming more aware of
the challenges of creating games during
these unpredictable times and making
realistic adjustments to shoot for
quality over hitting deadlines the
massive numbers of players ready to hop
on the newest release has proved the
need for better servers betas and tests
that give a smoother overall launch date
experience and i'm pretty optimistic
that all of those 2021 hurdles has set
us up for an action pack 2022 and yes
the stock shortages on the new gen
consoles and gpus have definitely been a
pain but a lot of these games will be
coming to last gen and optimized for a
variety of pcs too so not all hope is
lost if you haven't been able to upgrade
so what are you looking forward to the
most in gaming for 2022 let me know in
the comments and as always thank you so
much for watching we'll catch you next
time
[Music]
you